a dramatic scene is unfolding at the
last village
under isis control in syria where our
charlie dagda has been reporting from
the front lines
women and children are pouring out in
huge numbers as u.s backed syrian forces
make the final push against the
militants charlie met the families who
escaped to safety
u.s led forces here say they are
advancing today against the last
remnants of
isis militants backed up by american air
strikes and artillery
and by the hour those isis fighters are
losing
one of their last lines of defense human
shields
they've been pouring out of the last
isis-held village
in numbers no one here had expected
the women and children so very many
children
sons and daughters of isis members who
are long gone
still fighting or already dead
muhammad's husband was killed in an
airstrike leaving her to care for five
children on her own what does it mean to
you to see the end
of isis what is she they mean nothing to
me
they're trash they may have stayed with
isis until the very
end but the families here say it wasn't
out of choice they were forced to become
human shields but the more families that
come flooding out of that village
the easier it is for u.s led ground
troops
to move in they're estimated to be
around five to six hundred isis fighters
left
and top sdf official reader hillel says
there is
no escape at some point when it becomes
unwinnable for isis are you expecting
that they may
surrender or are you predicting a fight
to death
we know that most of the fighters inside
are the toughest left
and they may be looking for an escape
route but the only option is to
surrender
or die families here told us there
aren't many civilians left
the latest to flee from isis may be
among the last now the roughly 2
000 american forces who are here have
been a vital part of this
fight now the kurdish-led soldiers won't
allow us to film them but we've seen
them
everywhere from front-line fighting to
screening
isis suspects who are trying to sneak
out with those civilians
for cbs this morning charlie dagetta in
eastern syria
thank you charlie incredible reporting
there